hello
and welcome to another night of chess on
psychology
hopefully you're having a great time
and another point of
view go favi
yeah it's very important for me that's
fabi wins you know i live in san luis
he's in saint louis he's the
um pride of well
saint sandler's chess club um
so it's very important for us to
you know see him win and i still have a
his shirt from go favi 2000
so i hope that i get to bear a new goal
bobby one
i need to get one for you too rick fish
pc is joined uh as well and
i don't think he's exactly would fit in
the shirt but he's definitely looking
into jumping up here
all right so uh from what i see
everything is set sound good board looks
decent i got my
youtube going so um how's the viewers
doing
anybody has any favorite games
there has been so it looks like it's a
door so yeah it is
and there's a pc right down here too he
might grace us with his presence
and also i did something very weird
today i was trying to pick some games
from candidates and then
i um somehow misread the results but
anyways uh this this was a great game
i really enjoyed it it was the first one
of this live
so i'm sure most of you are aware of how
the candidates kind of
turned to be you know the whole
tournament was going on last year and
then coveted
and then they had to cancel it they
decided to actually cancel it i believe
the players also
um asked it too and
yeah nepo is another great one yeah if
poppy wasn't playing
nepal would be or or mpl
yeah one of those two actually would be
mine
yeah the game with the alexian ghost
game was also
kind of a i was like yes super
grassmasters
also play weirdly sometimes that was
kind of a good one
for me to watch and yeah there are so
many great games i had
i had a lot of trouble choosing but the
one thing i knew i definitely wanted to
do
was talk about the candidates so
here we are um this game was very very
great
but before we start jumping into it
i do want to make a tiny announcement
that
after we're done with our youtube
session we are going to switch to
twitter and analyze your games
so if you are playing a cool game or if
you already have a cool game already
make sure to be ready to join us in
about an hour a little over an hour
on twitch and share your game so
that being said hopefully you can um
start selecting games and time it a
little better too
and yeah that's what i wanted to talk
about as well alright
hopefully the cat won't try to um
break free his last week i don't know if
you guys remember last week
he was um very active just like
grabbing the door and meowing and
jumping up and down
right now he's being a good boy but
there's always the chance that he would
want to go
out and get some air for those of you
who are not in this area
yesterday was crazy nuts it was snowing
out here the day before that the weather
was so good like i was sunbathing
basically
and yesterday it was snowing today it's
kind of a
weird one too i didn't really leave my
room willingly
so alright you got the weather update
cat update
let's go so uh this was actually a very
great game
from what i remember after i was booking
the commentary and watched the
interviews and everything uh i believe
this was his and
um this was fabi's preparation but then
it was quite deep so i
really liked it i'm a huge fan of
preparation
it's if it's an advantage you should
take you should do it if you know who
you're playing you definitely should
prepare you should prepare so much that
you don't have to play with one single
move and i've done that bunch of times
myself
yeah um not potentially not
you know with a super grandmaster but
i've definitely i'm
a huge huge fan of um
huge fan of preparation
all right so we got a cool night off
going on
and so i want to guess for those of you
who haven't watched this game i want to
get tiny votes in
what do you think bobby chose after
bishop g5 what line do you think he goes
for
um alright that's
not no i it's a it's just people talk
people talk it's not even worth
considering it's
just yeah no
um is sicilian defense good
for a low rated player
um yeah honestly i think it's it's a
good choice to have
i wish i learned sicilian much earlier
in my life because by the time
i wanted to play it i was already like
2300
and i was hunting my norms and there was
so much pressure on it
so i think it is a good idea to kind of
have
that introduction to different openings
from both white and black
early on and so you're not really like
you have this wide variety of
choices and i think that could be
beneficial in the wrong
long run all right so
thank you for expressing your opinion
about what you think bobby did here
he went for f4 that's another that's a
good one
uh generally with bishop g5s you kind of
want to do long castle you know
uh in my earth but there is no rule that
says you can't
and you definitely have to do this long
castle immediately
as we'll see in this game that's not
what happened
so he followed by f4 queen b6 okay
um this isn't i it's been a while since
i played this line so
it's um
i want to get more opinions i don't want
to be the only one who
kind of talks about what white should do
what what shouldn't do
but one thing is for sure you got to
move this queen
where should you go also also this queen
b2
is something that is worth considering
for black because
um you know what it's not really going
to do something like this
it's possible but it you don't really
know where this knight wants to go it's
not
it's not the best idea to um put it
put it move it immediately i can
definitely make the sound quality better
there is a little tangled wire here as
long as i
move my laptop the sound quality should
be a tiny bit better
okay how is it now
a little better
all right um
let's see what else we got so knight b3
possible but not really necessary i
think when d2
is the better choice to go and
let's see what else we got after queen
bb
queen d2 what do you guys think about
queen taking on v2
oh sorry i keep forgetting you have
earbuds
sorry ben and tracy and whoever else
has your butts in
well that was explosive
recently i keep waking up with um sneeze
to
because peachy has been sleeping in my
bed for about a month now
every night and apparently when i'm
asleep he likes to make a neck beard and
sleep on my face
and yeah i've been having to take more
allergy pills
yeah okay um so
thank you thank you yeah taking is
definitely possible
but to be fair in a serious game
nobody has nobody has actually done this
with me but this queen b6 queen b2
yeah i mean it's there's nothing wrong
with it but
it's at the same time you always think
like ah why would i go eat that pun
such a hassle rook b1 queen a3 and it's
so
um so much preparation
right and that's what actually happened
in the game
so now i'm gonna ask you to tell me what
do you think black should do
should black take this or do you think
black can try and
um find another way to get some pieces
out
and find some activity and yes peachy
does mean cat
i literally named my cat cat he seems to
like it
because it's just really fluffy
well i mean i have my ipad very close by
because i'm reading the chat here so
that might be italia
my dad's name is elliot alright
um okay so right now you kind of want
your knights under attack so you either
have to take
or you have to attack or you don't
really want to move this knight that's
naturally
no no no no no we don't want to do that
so we don't want to have to move this
line that's just
no f5 is here taking is nothing no
um so
either you're gonna take this or you
could do
a little um like improv not the silly
improvise little like
counter attack i probably is the best
way to stay with h6
hey kitty don't do that
and so h6
yeah with h6 you're not going to take
this because
your king is still in the middle of the
board and then
this is just gonna be pleasant for black
now black is the one with advantage
open files open bishops yeah
so after a6 you gotta move the bishop
now
in this game nbl decided to
take good choice take good choice and
knight d7
so
what do we think about this position to
be honest g5
is also a possibility but knight d7
is the hot stuff in theory these these
days
now what do you think white should do
we still got a bunch of pieces to get
out to be fair uh
from it's my knowledge that this was
already all preparation
from fabulous side but nothing wrong
with it having a strong crap kudos to
him
ah um phil me too i do want to show the
kitty but right now he's preoccupied
staring at a squirrel behind the window
he will join us sooner or later he's not
gonna stay
too um he's gonna
give me these kind of stairs that will
open the door i want to go out
i think i've accidentally conditioned
him into whenever i'm sitting behind
this desk because it's so close to the
door
he wants to go outside all right great i
actually
like this bishop c4 idea but not at the
moment i do think that
we need to get our pieces out but bishop
c4 is not the right way the problem with
bishop c4 is
um well he's also going to develop
or what if i take clear take here knight
e6 exists and it could
raise some complications cool
complications
but i don't think this works our pieces
are just
not ready enough
and unfortunately black is somehow
surviving this and we don't really it's
not
not the exact way we want to go about it
bishop c4 would be good
um if we if like for example my bishop
was just
improving its position not necessarily
just um
not necessarily just because your bishop
on c4 is not exactly attacking anything
so hi php so what about knight e4
how do we like knights going to e4
do
all right let's see what else we got
queen of four
[Music]
um i like knight i like this knight e4
so the thing with knight e4
is that i have serious threats my first
threat being
you can't get your pieces out so my
first
idea being that i am first of all for
example if you take knight takes e5
now what do you think our knight can do
remember um
we think that taking good this d8 is a
potential
interest i'll um
also robber levy um i appreciate your
opinion
but i don't accept it i don't believe in
it
and um it's kind of hurtful
everybody has different opinion on this
matter but it's
it's just i don't think i
i it's not true if it is true then
my whole belief system in chess is not
it's kind of crooked but i don't believe
it's true it's i've known alexian cool
he's such a great kid i interviewed him
like what was it five years ago maybe
six years ago oh my god i'm getting so
old
but no
and i feel like the sneeze is coming up
yeah knight b5
uh knight e6 is also interesting knight
b5 i think is the best one though
you want to give checkmate over here and
checkmate over here
no way to stop both of it good job
um so after knight e4 what do you think
is black's best move
thank you thank you everybody who are uh
who found knight b5 yeah so no more
knight e5
what do you think is black's best move
what do you think kitty
never play f6 i kind of
that's maybe like 99 percent of time
don't play f6 but yeah
basically it's a yasser's move
technically could be
gaster would like this one
no bishop before it's just a free bishop
wouldn't really help black's position
so two moves are worth considering one
of them is g5
because you kind of kick this bishop and
you sever this connection
to the d8 square but g5 also has its
problems because now my knight on e4 is
gonna be bomb
so uh g5 is not the way black would want
to go
mbl simply took queen takes a2 and
this position is equal which is so weird
because
black has two extra pawns white has so
much activity
but the position is equal so after queen
takes a2
simple moves rook d1 my goal is to
come poke you on the d8 square now black
plays queen d5
poking you back going after some of your
weak pawns as well
and now finally what do you think wise
should do this is another
critical move when i was watching this
game
i had a little trouble finding this
not trouble more like it wasn't exactly
my first choice
so what do you think this move should be
it's not a hard move
it's a very logical move
i'll give you guys maybe about 30
seconds try to think about
what opponent wants how can you activate
some of your pieces that are
not necessarily as well activated
uh no right now careful because your
pawn and your knight are under attack
so you don't you can't just play
something like you can't just like
develop your bishop or your pawn
so interesting okay i'm annie yeah
you're correct we need three first
yeah queenie you are defending this
night you're opening up your rook
and you are create you're also kind of
like it's not exactly
that but you're kind of like keeping
like a half eye open on the king
i like that yeah so now if
knight takes b and knight takes e5 what
do you think white's gonna do
white has a very strong move which kind
of um
leads to a super cool win right now what
do you think white's gonna do
you got the knight correct but not
knight e6
knight b3 yeah knight b3 is the best one
the problem with knight
taking on e6 is simply check
and you still have your threads but it
kind of
slows it down you can't exactly play
stuff like this
because then bishop takes it and point
is defending the eight no
knight b5 is possible but then he can
take and just pick up the knight and we
do we don't want to really give up extra
slaps on my p3
no point a5 checks no way for queen to
defend the eight square
and the queen is going to drop
all right um so
now what about queen takes e5
what do you think white should do now
for those of you who have seen this game
you
might have an easier time choosing
between these moves
but um knight c6 for who oh i
set up knight b3 um nice c6 i think the
easiest way to look at it is kling could
take the rook
you take back and then he would just eat
your knight
in this complex i agree uh we don't
necessarily i think bishop g3 is
interesting but your bishop is
still very useful where it is so we
don't really need to move it
however uh one other thing that we could
consider
is okay so we had a bunch of problem
with this
check right with this diagonal so whoa
so let's just close it up
let's just close up this diagonal
oh hello kitty and your main instructor
has arrived
we move the microphone around so he can
sit somewhere ah don't type on the
laptop but here
okay
all righty we got the we got the cat in
the house
he's with he was attention deprived i
didn't look at him for like two seconds
all right let's go ahead um
so right now c3 is a very nice move
because
you simply block this check
possibilities and now it's kind of clear
why it is eventually gonna do
a short castle right so the question
is how are we going to
um where should we put this bishop
now black plays bishop c5 it's not a
serious threat it's kind of
it's not like you're gonna take it
because you drop the queen um
it's just like just pressure black is
trying to develop
white is trying to
do the same and also keep in mind this
f5 is something that could pop up
so it's time we're not going to be able
to do anything on d8 so let's kick this
queen away
and now what do you think we should do
this was a very very cool move what do
you think
white should do here
what do you think
she is gmp she isn't he
certainly acts like one joins us in all
these hard positions
and leaves as soon as the position gets
a little complex good job
so i have a suggestion for bishop c4
why how would bishop c4 work what if he
takes it
and again if you by any chance have
missed the live commentary
you can watch it again you don't need to
just watch
this game for from my side
so you are more than welcome to watch
the official commentary
that um yasser maurice and
alejandra they're doing and if you need
more languages i'm sure you can find
more of them on twitch
and anywhere basically because this is
the hot stuff that's happening in the
chess world
basically for the year so
all right so bishop c4 what if clean
takes it serious question
what would you do now
oh
exactly bishop d6 good one and to be
fair before bishop c4 you could have
also considered bishop d6
if take now knight b5 and go for this
guy
however
yeah yeah chest 24 with magnus's
commenter is also amazing
however this bishop c4 was a novelty
and so good for bobby
and after take that in the game after
take bishop d6 happened yes
you can't really take it because it's
bye bye queen careful with that
you can't really move it let's say if
you move it that's not going to work for
you
you can just move this bishop and simply
start enjoying your checks
so you're a little busted now in the
game black found the best move what do
you think is the best move for
black
what do you think uh
no well technically i manny yes
but um 1900 played this line up until
instead of bishop c4 bishop d6 in 2013
so technically it wasn't a novelty until
bishop c4
but in high level yes
and i have cat hair in my coffee
no taking here wouldn't also help but i
think it's interesting to
mention now you can move the queen and
simply
queen g3 or even cast the link should be
interesting enough
because you can never actually castle
because i have that diagonal
so i guess potentially yes but
does knight c6 work
no because if right now knight c6
i'm just going to take it over here take
back
check
now same thing e5 i'm just going to take
it over here white has a simple thread
knight f6 yes again if you have seen
this game
nothing wrong with that you are more
than welcome to help me
as my like ta and just throw in hints
in the chat not necessarily say the best
move just like throw hints and like
white ones this black wants this so what
should do this to stop
black wanting that stuff like that
all right all right so pj had a little
snack he's joining us again
for this after short break
after knight of six what do you think we
should do we can definitely
eat this right it's kind of free but
with what what should we eat that poor
guy with
thank you i am peaches ta at this point
start this is mama
hey
okay good good we have a decision thank
you taking with the knight
is the best one yes the taking with
bishop doesn't exactly work
and there's no other move here after
knight f6 that actually worth
thinking about because you've given up a
piece so
you need to actually um start receiving
you're either retrieving that piece or
you have like a
killer attack on unfortunately you don't
have a killer attack going
so the best you could do is get that
piece back
control that's diagonal and enjoy your
time
nothing wrong with that all right so
after uh take on c5 knight d5
where should we place our clean i think
there are two
they're like two two places that are
definitely worth
considering but one of them can be
eliminated
quite fast
so where do you think we should go with
the queen
so that's the thing going um queen to g3
or d2 point the problem is
that i can simply just get the will
get this knight out anywhere and that's
not gonna be very pleasant that's not
exactly
what we want as white we don't want my
phone to happily develop
the problem with queen g3 is that it
looks good but
queen takes c3 don't forget to think
about what your opponent wants
and it's a much better ending game for
black he has extra pawns
and white doesn't have enough stuff to
um to
you know attack in that endgame so where
else can the coin go
we're kind of running out of squares so
point e5
what the idea with 25 is still i'm
attacking on g7 i'm still trying to
hold my own and enjoy the position but
at the same time i don't want to
exchange queens so
we got that going as well
so after queen e5 mbl is
realizing that okay i gotta you know
stop eating ponds because if i eat right
here
king f2 and white scan starts to do like
those fake castles and
that's not really going to be helpful
for black's lack of development and
also g7 is falling right peach peach
so after um
knight d5 queen e5 black made simple
moves you want to eat my pawn i don't
want you to eat my pawn
fair enough now this is another
masterpiece here
so let's take a quick look at it what do
you think white should do
this is such a cool move
what this fish
night sacrifice you guys got it yeah
i meant if you remember and if you want
to share you're more than welcome to do
so
just do it subtly like hey guys what do
you think about
those knights like working together
something like that
taking on e6 is the best one because
honestly if we could castle
i think we should try that but at the
moment that's impossible
and the other problem is that if i give
black two three moves
because this is right now white has
dynamic advantage black is just gonna
attack to clean
now my queen gotta move then black would
try to exchange queens and
black is not completely hopeless it's
just that
um white wish i mean i wish i had
another like
my pieces were a little bit more active
or like had a pawn here
trying to attack but because we don't we
only have three more pawns left
we have to be very careful with them so
knight takes e6
this is dynamic advantage we need to go
attack attack attack attack
take back okay we're gonna take that
anyways
now there's a question does it matter
which night uh a little bit
yes because now there's this check and
let's say if you play
king f2 take you can't really take that
anymore
the queen is um your queen is a little
occupied
unfortunately does that make sense
yeah so we don't want to do that let's
take with the chorus tonight my queen
defending over here
take i take if you try to be all cute
and take it over here
which is what happened in the game
because if you don't do that your
position is a little in the pickle you
can you cannot take that that's just
checkmate waiting
yeah no no no this is this is too
hopeless for black
if you want any type of fighting chances
kitty
you should exchange these queens and
this is what happened in the game now
you got to be careful because rook under
attack
ninth under attack i already have given
that 90s extra
and another two pawns so what do you
think
it did what do you think about floppy's
preparation we do know that fabi won
this game
but what do we think about this position
is this at the position
we were hoping for to be a fair i have
had preparations myself where
you prepare this like crazy line and
if like opponent finds every single best
move
okay they might end up with a tiny bit
of advantage or
um like a pawn extra but it's like still
very equal it's not that i
prepared for equalization
or i guess i prepared for an equal
position it's that
if my opponent is qualified enough and
smart enough
and good good enough chess player then
of course
he he or she can find equalize
to find a way to equalize the position
but even with that
it's gonna be such a mental strain and
psychological battle because
it's like so much thinking about
okay is my position surviving for my
opponent
so yes i think this was a good choice of
preparation
uh okay knight c7 king f7
and now let's please for the love of god
let's move this trick
uh this is possible but the king just
runs
and when i start attacking it there's
this checks and it's kind of it falls
out of balance
so that's why we just say okay rook d3
just
do that now uh if something unlike rk7
to try to save the rook that's under
attack all right
i will be castling first no sorry
i guess i could actually castle this
king moves
and i can eat over here uh this
is another cool end game black still has
two extra pawn but
these pieces are not active and i'm
going to try and start poking your
brook here and there so it's going to be
a long game
in the game uh mbl just going for knight
e4
i agree yeah it was quite in quite
impressive that mvl found
every move over the board and even
though he was out prepped yeah he
and bill is very good playing on his
feet
all right um okay king g6 is kind of a
given finally we gotta eat that bad boy
and
now what do we think what do you think
white what do you think about this
position does white have advantage
this end game was so cool slash
weird i wish i had like more words to
describe my feelings towards this end
game
but this was just one of those end games
that
was well in chess you in order to win
the game
you need a bunch of stuff first of all
you need to
uh you know play good second of all you
need a
generous opponent third of all you need
luck
and gladly fabi had all the three
elements in this position
in this game so good for him and me
since
i'm team fabi
so anyone likes black's position
right now feel free to speak up
i manny i agree drake a7 just looked
weird
and very passive but it would have been
the best fight yes
but i guess mvl wanted to play find some
some activity because
all game he's been kind of just
responding to fobby's threats
so i i'm assuming it's i mean it's very
mentally draining
so you don't want to fight like that you
don't want to just
always be on your toes waiting to see
what opponent wants to do and just kind
of
respond to that
all right so right now what i see that's
so let's see anyone suggestions
it is right to move and i do agree that
knight got a run
let's get that nice rolling okay rt8
putting my pressure on this bad boy
what about this bad boy should i try to
play like a rook d
one type of deal or should i just take
on c8
oh the cat sniffing
what do we think
actually why am i why are you whining
it's a good position don't mind i'm in
an
attempt to make more room for
my master
cats
uh iron milling i intend to do as much
as i can for the end game but
i don't want to go too much in depth
because first of all
the commentators did that second of all
i
am also here to analyze your games after
this one and i don't want to take too
much time
away from that
that is true uh brian i agree i thought
these pawns would make something cool
happen
anyways tank you gotta take and so
it's just one of those weird positions
there's a rook versus a knight
and two pawns the more you can uh
as whites the more activity you can have
the better the more you can um
try to eat those pawns the better but
there's a high risk
of draw so that's another thing that we
should be cautious of hello
hi pewdiepie alright so what do you
think white should do now
should do we care about this bishop
should we move it
should we make the cat sit down
okay kitty you are being a little weird
you want to sit down
i'll massage you okay let me put the
ipad up so there's more
room for his majesty your majesty
please sit down thank you and let me
move the microphone
basically yes he's like okay mama i want
to sit here
please make the room for me right
and whatever his majesty wants his
majesty gets
and she's a big boy
[Music]
yeah he is trying he's kind of sitting
on the mouse right now
so i apologize for any shortcomings on
the chessboard from my end
me too we definitely should keep this
bishop thank you thank you for that
comment
yeah bishop e3 is the best one to be
honest something like maybe
um that's the thing like the bishop has
to stay in this diagonal
if you go try to go to f4 it's just out
of balance
bishop a3 is the best one uh you could
potentially try to move the stroke but
it's too early oh no they're not there
it's too early yeah bishop a3
and now in the game fabi did amazing job
here and the game rook f4 is the best
one you need to keep your pieces active
and
the knights are great in center so we
gotta kick him away
right php yeah and now we need to have
this knight
kicked out of center there we go
and this move also was quite um
challenging for me for the first minute
what do you think white should do now
trading rooks um potentially
but in black's not gonna go for that
what about this bishop can i make this
bishop be any better
yeah bishop b2 thank you yes looks weird
but it works i promise
yeah so um now you are
threatening and you know potentially
eating over here
so manville went 97 it's not
yeah sydney you're correct bishop b2 is
trying to just weaken the pawn exactly
good eye and uh the idea of a dirk d6
i guess that's possible but knight f5
kind of just
stops that idea for that for the time
being
it's possible but i think
uh the way i'm trying to maybe push on
the
um kingside pawns is a little bit better
of choice
all right so we push the pawns
what about g4
the problem is rook c6 and i don't
really want to make my king
too lonely
there is a question regarding bishop f8
let me address it
bishop f8 origins king f7
uh maybe take and then check king goes
back
right here i guess this this is okay
i guess king f7 not the first um
the best choice what's your threat to
just take and give check
what if i just move my king away
now if you take i can just do 9-5
dry
yeah i don't think this works
unfortunately
well actually fortunately yeah a bishop
of faith is
has a nice little trick but no also what
if you're kept seven
okay check king moves and then you take
that that's okay
i guess but no i mean mission of faith
is a
tricky but it's not the right move for
the position
it's tricky in the sense that you want
to go after the g7 pawn
but it's it wouldn't work i mean i guess
if you're playing maybe
lower um lower level maybe
okay bishop b2 let's get rid of that
and h4 h5 and here uh white is kind of
going strong but at the same time it's a
little scary because there's
like still two pawns two connected pass
pawns so
what do you think white should do here
what do you think white should go for
can i try and eat anything
delicious
yeah let's go after this guy black is
not completely hopeless black of course
has this little tricks to still try to
fork me here and there
okay now i'm attacking the knight the
knight's gotta move
check up take so now we
still have one pond left as white but it
can be very tricky
um even if we eat a6 which we soon will
it's still not as winning as
uh we would hope for it to be there's
still a lot of tricks that black can do
so 95 check
and now what do we think about this
position
is white better
it's very tricky but is
lights better
what do you think bishop do you think
white's better
so white is better but it needs a lot of
skill
and luck for whites to be able to win
this game
so we know fabi has the skills
and since he won we know that he also
got has the luck
so let's just see how it was done
and stop touching my rush yeah king g3
you gotta activate your king you gotta
try and still
keep your opponents on his toes
get the king activated lovely
finally we can eat this pawn all right
now i have um
i have made the mistake of uh drawing
similar positions in my days but
fab is not me so um it's
very important to actually be able to
understand the
ideas behind these moves
so for example when um
oh trying to
ah so for example when my chat stops
working
ah there we go
lovely
so what do you think i kind of actually
want to get a little uh opinion on what
do you guys think
is happening and yeah father is amazing
that's why
i'm rooting for him and also the title
of this
cool stream being go fabi
which could have been gopishi but what
do you think
okay maybe bringing the rook maybe
okay so you're kind of people are
considering pushing this pawn
i think yes with a little too early we
don't we don't we want to keep that we
never knew
so um
nicolas yeah exactly that's kind of the
idea if i could somehow trade this rook
for the night
the pawn is better for my pawn to you
know be all the way in the back
so king e4 okay that's the knight
getting cornered
great for me now
the idea is clear i want to keep my king
in the center
i don't want your knight in the center
or your king and i'm eventually going to
go rook g3 and push your king to
uh corner as well okay
no problem knight on f5 is not a problem
but
now trick question should i play g4 or
not
no i agree we shouldn't this knight came
from d6
so it probably wants to go back and
remember in end games the idea of rook
staying uh exactly in this position from
the night
is a golden we want that we want to push
the knight away push the knight away
push the knight away
why not well ernesto we don't want to
rush with g4
we want g4 to be
very well timed because if i play g4
then even if i manage to somehow get
exchange the rook and the knight and win
your pawn my pawn on g4 and your kingdom
g6 on my king on f4 is a draw
the end game would be the content game
would be a draw
yep rook d3 is better because
now the knights gotta move you can't
move the king the only piece you can do
is the knight
and we all made a mistake he should have
played knight to e7
followed it by trying to keep the knight
somewhat active and
would have been a better defense he
played knight h6 which was wrong good
for us
chequito king move away now your knight
can't really go anywhere which is
perfect
i'm just gonna play chill okay your
night's going even
more backwards oh great for me uh
king of five has a slight inaccuracy
what do you think
is better move for white here
what do you think is the best move for
whites here
since that night is so in a pickle
actually i kind of want to eat pickle
cravings sour and salty stuff
maybe because in the last few days i've
been eating so much chocolate
i really should stop eating chocolate
not forever
just tone it down
uh rook h3 potentially
but what about going the other way
or even c3 or b3 doesn't i mean like
going going long so i could um kind of
just do waiting moves
that the goal the thing is that with
these waiting moves
eventually black is gonna get busted
because
let's say king g6 okay i'll just go over
k5
knight c6 all right i'm just gonna go
backwards to
backrank two or
or i could even just play like rook d5
you can't really do knights e5s
oh well taking heroes is still a little
too early this would still
because king gets to go to g5 at the end
but that's kind of the idea we want to
have that like right now
if you were to be cute and move your
king you'll definitely take that
so
yeah yeah exactly anyways uh in the game
fabi didn't do that he kind of rushed it
with king f5
got checked got another check but it's
not the end of the world
he can still go ahead and kick that
light
97 was a mistake knight c7 would have
been better to try and keep it a little
more
um challenging but with the knight on e7
now
uh rook c3 would be the best one to
avoid knight c6
how about fabi chose a different trial
than he went kanga for
and did a little repeating
and now he
chose another approach instead of going
for something like
rookie tree to go to the um more
freer side he chose rookie stream
but he still oh he still has a better
position
you got gotta sit down man and now
what do you think black afternoon king
g6 what do you think
we should
you do see you can see peach's ears
it kind of looks weird but here's a
lovely
heating shoe what do you think
if you need to stop black from entering
yeah uh but not
gaming can get four is definitely
possible however
by key uh playing something like
rocketry is much better and that is what
fabi
did
now in this game mvl made a mistake with
king f7
knight e7 would have been better but you
see the problem is you never
know where exactly to get that knight i
i'm guessing the knights being on g5 is
kind of more
the most comforting one but then
eventually this king is gonna move away
and we would have king f5 so
[Music]
i don't think that's going to be as
pleasant anyways so king f7
this game most of it i mean for the end
game portion
was just trying to um
find the best way to kind of poke the
opponent
nothing wrong with that that's actually
great you're trying to break his spirit
his position get your pieces in all
right
so um now what do you think white should
do
we're almost done with this game five
more moves or so
change d5 not exactly
king f4 yes so the
king of five is also a little too
immature because simply check and
it's not it's kind of like this doing
the same dance
so king f4 i'm gonna wait for you see
what you do i might be able to do king
f5
so um here mbo played knight h6
now this knight can only go back to g8
so let's do rook g3 when you play knight
g8 now i have a cool killer move what do
you think is this cool killer move
it's a very cool move
uh might let me see no taking is not
no no no no no if your king was on f5
yes
but it's not there and you can't do king
five now
but you have the right idea how can i
get my king closer to opponent sixth
rank
king five you just get checked so you
can't do that
what else you guys
we tried bringing the king from the
f-file
failed to try to bring the king from the
other side failed
what about king bringing to the other
side
and rook h3 this knight goes to e7
if you check just the king goes up
exactly let's bring the king closer king
g4
amazing move for by fabi
and the thing is if now you play like
knight g8
then it's ganzo because i take take and
then i'll just come eat this guy
right so you can't do that as black
so black tries to keep the knight active
but that's also a
lost position now knight f4 might be
coming up so we gotta stop
that and now what do we do
the king moved away my king is in prime
position
what do you think we should do now
two more moves and black resigned it is
super winning now
just have to figure out how to get to
that f6 pawn
push yes let's push first uh king g6
king g6 and not exactly is i guess it's
possible but
you can't really do that because the
knight gets too close so let's just play
g4 no need to worry about any of these
king e5 king g6
there you go you can't move the ninth
because i'll take that you can't really
do that because i'll just play king g7
and i'll rook f5 you and then i can just
actually eat here honestly
and push that yeah that was such a
beautiful game
and you guys kind of knew this strategy
as soon as we got
to one rook versus one group one pawn
versus one night one pawn
you kind of knew that okay we should get
this to pawn and game
but it was kind of the matter of how
that might have been challenging to some
of us
and finding the most accurate moves are
never easy even fabi didn't find the
super accurate moves in this game nobody
can always play accurate moves
so that's why that's that's why this
game was actually one of my favorite
ones
because it shows that you can make
second best moves or not best moves
here and there and still win the game
it's not it's
chess is not just about finding the best
levels all the time
you need some luck too all right uh we
are gonna take a short break probably a
little less than 10 minutes
and we will see you on twitch have your
games ready we're going to look at them
on leachat
on our segment of switch to twitch
i'll see you guys in about 10 minutes
make sure to show up to our twitch
channel
have your games ready uh preferably on
leeches to share with me
and for those of you who
haven't really been in the chess world
in the last few days
candidates is going on and the chess
club is doing official commentary
so uh tuning to watch those every
morning
well actually kind of really early
morning in the u.s
but um so yeah make sure to follow the
events
and i'll see you on twitch shortly
if you have any questions habits ready
for our